se lécher les doigts dans un labo de
chimie c'est pas un truc à faire c'est
pourtant comme ça que Constantin falberg
a découvert le sucre artificiel pendant
ces expériences sur le goudron de
Houilles il a une grosse fringale il en
poigne un morceau de pain et là c'est
sucré tout ce qu'il touche devient
délicieux même la serviette pour
s'essuyer la bouche il court labo et ne
fait surtout pas ça chez vous il goûte
tout jusqu'à trouver le responsable qui
donne vraiment pas faim une heureuse
coïncidence qui révolutionne l'industrie
sucrière de son époque ça porte un nom
la sérendipité à quoi ressemblerait ta
vie sans elle voyons ça avec ses 8
erreurs de la science qui ont changé ton
quotidien comment les recherches
douteuses d'un médecin antiseps t'ont
aidé à mieux manger John Harvey
Kellogg's a une obsession lutter contre
la masturbation une mission qui lui
aurait été confiée par Dieu plus de 30
inventions à son actif machine sportive
viande végétale beurre de cacahuète
toujours avec le même but assanir le
corps pour éloigner les pulsions
sexuelles pour lui il faut bannir viande
sucre graisse tout ce qui du goût et se
faire souffrir au sport pourquoi parce
que prendre du plaisir surtout à table
donnerai envie de se masturber je ne
veux pas savoir à quoi ressemblait ses
repas de famille ce qui est rigolo c'est
que la science moderne a prouvé
l'inverse manger sain et faire du sport
augmente ta libido ça explique pourquoi
c'était rapidement marchait pas bien
l'obligeant à des méthodes plus extrêmes
mettre en cas des aubergines ou en
couper un bout sans anesthésie rigolez
pas mesdames il y a aussi un traitement
pour vous abricots de l'acide carbonique
samedi sous pas la peau mais ça fait
très mal vous continuez à en avoir envie
il retire tout en chirurgie un gros
barbare ça grande idée antipulsion un
petit déjeuner pour réduire l'appétit à
midi et oui au début du siècle dernier
ça n'existait presque pas en Occident on
se contentait d'une boisson réveil café
ou 20 mais il faudrait pas te donner des
envies dès le matin des crée donc
l'aliment le plus fade possible les
granola les biscuits réduits en poudre
recuit puis cassé en petits bouts sa
recette blé complet avoine et eau sans
sel sans sucre sans saveur il y a un
défaut trop dur on s'y casse les dents
hors de question de les laisser tremper
dans du lait sinon ça ramollit une
mastique pas et t'aura envie de te
c'est religieux un jour qui travaille en
cuisine un patient l'appelle pour une
urgence il parle ils sont derrière lui
dégring de blé dans de l'eau le
lendemain il les utilise quand même pas
de gâchis il est cuit pas ce rouleau
corn flakes magique non tremper les
céréales une dizaine d'heures démarre le
processus de germination libérant des
enzymes qu'il a prédigère elle découpe
les sucres complexes et les protéines en
molécules simples la graine devient plus
souple s'aplatie en flocon j'en avais et
celle d'autres céréales jusqu'à choisir
le maïs car moins de goût mais
aujourd'hui les corn flakes c'est bon
sucré oui à cause d'une trahison son
frère William Kelloggs qui suggère
d'ajouter miel chocolat noir pour
augmenter les ventes le médecin refuse
les deux se frites William fonde sa
propre usine et connaît un succès
immédiat sans lequel tu n'aurais jamais
pu manger de céréales au petit déjeuner
vous pouvez aussi changer le monde à la
tête d'une armée magique avec Call of
Dragon's notre sponsor c'est le
blockbuster des jeux mobiles de l'année
dernier chef-d'oeuvre de l'équipe
derrière rise of Kingdoms réalise tes
rêves de con prend le contrôle du
continent de tamaris à la tête d'une des
trois factions du jeu tu dois construire
ton propre village recruté de puissants
orques mage ou guerrier avec
d'innombrables autres héros tu as même
un bémote EPIC pour tout détruire de mon
côté j'ai préféré la grasse et
l'élégance avec la faction des
gardiennes de la source et leur mignonne
elle fait Sylvanian et grâce à leur héro
garboi je profite de capacités de
renforcement d'infanterie toutes les
races sont leurs spécificité du bonus de
bâtiment jusqu'au renforcement d'unité
de quoi construire l'armée de ses rêves
à condition de faire les bons choix qui
attaquaient que développé dans mon arbre
de technologie et de recherche et
surtout comment gérer au mieux mes
ressources le jeu est gratuit dispo sur
toutes les plateformes mobiles et PC en
crossplay jouer avec la communauté vos
amis ou ceux qui le deviendront créer
des alliances pour régner sur la carte
ça ne sera je offre à bonus spécial avec
le code affiché télécharger call of
Dragon's liant un artiste et un
entrepreneur ton sauvé la vie tu as bien
mis ton casque dans un monde alternatif
sans invention accidentelle tes parents
te posent toujours la question avant
démarrer la voiture remontez-vous du
caoutchouc ça prend mal les chocs ça
manque d'adhérence ça suce très vite
surtout quand il fait chaud tu dois
t'arrêter régulièrement sinon elles
fondent pas très pratique mais les pneus
aujourd'hui sont toujours en caoutchouc
ou non c'est plus compliqué que ça
Charles Goodyear connaît bien les
défauts de cette matière sa dernière
invention des sacs postaux a été un
grand succès en hiver jusqu'à ce qu'on
se rende compte qu'ils font des au
soleil il commence par essayer de les
rendre moins collants grâce aux travaux
d'autres chercheurs qui ont ajouté du
soufre pendant une démonstration
publique il affirme être à deux doigts
de trouver la recette miracle fou rire
général il s'énerve balançant de ses
morceaux en l'air il finit sa course sur
un poêle à bois mais au lieu de fondre
le caoutchouc Bruni devient très
élastique mais comment qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé les chaînes microscopiques
qui le composent ne tiennent pas en
place la pression les frottements ou la
chaleur les font partir en voyage des
agrégeant la matière il mélangeait du
soufre puis le cuir accroche les chêne
les unes aux autres appuie sur le
caoutchouc il s'écrase arrête il reprend
sa forme initiale ajoutez d'autres
ingrédients modifie la réaction
l'accélère augmente la résistance
l'élasticité ou la colore le dosage est
précis sinon ça se transforme en ébolite
plus dur utilisé pour les isolants
électriques les becs d'instruments ou
les boules de bowling vous dire ne
comprend pas bien le phénomène il le
décrit le nomme vulcanisation trois ans
plus tard il trouve la pièce manquante
une cuisson à la vapeur plus précise et
contrôlable rendant le caoutchouc
résistant frottement et aux variations
de température il aurait pu devenir
riche mais un autre scientifique dépose
le brevet en premier bon ça finit bien
non une des plus grandes marques de
pneus portent son nom non un hommage
sans lien avec lui il est mort couvert
de dettes après même avec de bons pneus
je te conseille pas de retirer ton
casque ta voiture à un autre problème le
pare-brise du verre un choc violent le
brise projette des éclats mortels dans
l'habitacle ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui car une loi de 1983 a rendu
obligatoire l'utilisation du verre
feuilleté ultra résistant sans risque
d'éclat et découvert par une maladresse
d'Édouard Bénédictus artiste et chimiste
en 1902 il mène des recherches sur les
décoratif c'est intéressant à plusieurs
produits dont le celluloïde c'est les
chers tombent mais n'éclate pas il se
fissure en étoile il comprend aussitôt
ce qui s'est passé le plastique à
l'intérieur accroche au verre et le
retient c'est des années plus tard qu'il
perçoit le potentiel en lisant le
journal une femme tuée par un pare-brise
ça fait tilt il invente le triplex
souvent des millions de vies le principe
est simple un film plastique entre deux
plaques de verre il retient les éclats
et absorbe le choc si l'impact est petit
on peut même le réparer bonjour je suis
Olivier de Carglass les additifs
changent ses propriétés filtres anti-UV
panneau solaire paroi coupe-feu isolant
thermique ou par balle
ton goûter est-il vraiment le fruit du
hasard tu as bien failli ne jamais
manger tes gâteaux préférés en 1938 une
aubergiste américaine prépare des
biscuits secs sauf qu'elle est à court
de chocolat pâtissier elle fouille ses
placards tombe sur une tablette mi
sucrée ça fera l'affaire elle a brisé en
morceaux l'ajoute à sa préparation puis
en fourne 20 minutes plus tard surprises
le chocolat ne sait pas mélanger à la
pâte la raison les deux ne cuisent pas à
la même vitesse le chocolat est le
premier à fondre devient liquide mais
reste emprisonné l'eau et les graisses
de la pâte lui font barrage des pépites
concert leur forme un délicieux cookies
la recette connaît un succès immédiat
racheté par Nestlé pour en faire un
argument de vente une belle histoire
racontée par des dizaines de sites dont
la page wikipédia sauf qu'elle est
fausse Wakefield like piqué elle est
expérimenté pour créer une nouvelle
recette aucune erreur ici pas la seule
légende du genre la tarte tatin une
cuisinière a oublié la pâte et là donc
ajouter par-dessus en réalité ça
existait avant une spécialité à
régionale preuve qu'il faut parfois se
méfier sur les découvertes accidentelles
mais il y a bien une chose qui aurait pu
jamais exister dans ton placard tes
sachets de thé une boisson découverte en
financière dont la consommation serait
accidentelle une feuille de thé tombée
par hasard dans la bouche d'un homme
empoisonné la mâche et hop guéri alors
oui ça se mange il y a même des salades
mais ça ne soigne pas le poison chez
nous on consomme sur tout le thé en
infusion obligé d'utiliser une grande
théière c'est un peu long à mettre en
place faut faire une grande quantité pas
pratique jusqu'à l'invention du sachet
de thé par Thomas Sullivan il envoie des
échantillons de thé dans des petits
sachets en soie pour conserver la
fraîcheur mais les clients se plaignent
pratique mais la soie est trop épaisse
ça ralentit l'infusion les pochons ont
été détournés de leur usage certains
n'ayant pas compris qu'ils étaient
censés en retirer le thé l'idée plaie
alors Sullivan le retravaille remplace
la soie par de la gaz une étoffe tressée
individuelle sans lavage et économique
le sachet gagne vite en popularité et
faisant du thé la boisson la plus
consommée au monde pourquoi cette vidéo
ne devrait pas exister tous les matins
tu te lèves allume smartphone consulte
tes messages discutant avec des amis à
l'autre bout du monde une technologie
incroyable impossible sans les ondes
électromagnétiques découvertes par une
série de coïncidences William Herschel
essaye de déterminer quelle partie du
spectre lumineux produit le plus de
chaleur il décompose un rayon de soleil
avec un prisme projetant un arc-en-ciel
sur son bureau il est dépose un
thermomètre sur chaque couleur plus deux
dans l'ombre de chaque côté celui plaça
à côté du rouge s'emballe il est brûlant
après vérification il en déduit
l'existence d'un rayon invisible les
infrarouges un autre scientifique lui
emboîte le pas l'année suivante
remplaçant les thermomètres par une
substance qui noircit au soleil le
chlorure d'argent tu as peut-être vu ça
en chimie les rayons du soleil cassent
la molécule et oxyde l'argent la
réaction la plus forte a lieu à côté du
violet les ultraviolets ça inspire hand
spinner stud sa théorie chauffée
électriquement du métal va les monter
pour la vérifier il branche une pile sur
une barre métallique avec une boussole à
côté l'aiguille bouge mais pas dans la
direction prévue le métal n'est pas
aimanté mais ça provoque chose
l'existence d'un champ électromagnétique
il comprend
c'est là que débarque lydieforest connue
pour sa tendance à plagier en 1904 il
tombe sur la valve de Fleming l'ancêtre
de la diode vous connaissez l'ampoule un
filament métallique chauffé
électriquement pour produire de la
lumière sauf qu'ici on utilise un
courant électrique négatif provoquant
l'émission de petites particules les
électrons en remplaçant dans le tube une
plaque chargée positivement on les
attire loin du filament formant comme un
nuage d'électrons très sensible aux
champs électromagnétiques en mesurant
ces variations on perçoit les ondes
radio tu as sans doute expérimenté ce
phénomène
les résultats d'une interférence dans
ton enceinte pour éviter l'accusation
plagiat di forest bricole ajoutant une
grille entre les filaments et la plaque
l'utilité lui-même ne sait pas trop
moduler le courant électrique dans la
grille modifier le nuage d'électrons ça
amplifie le signal radio pas très bien
il a ajouté du gaz dans son tube à vide
réduisant ainsi son efficacité en 1912
il perd son procès contre Fleming les
juges estiment que son audio n'est
qu'une palpopie une invention
inutile d'autres scientifiques rachètent
son brevet voyant son potentiel
détection plus des ondes radio réduisant
la taille des antennes modulation et
aussi l'action du signal transmettant
des informations plus précises sans
interférence entre les différentes
stations d'émissions l'Audion devient
l'objet le plus important de
l'électronique moderne posant les bases
de tout ce que tu utilises aujourd'hui
mais si ça découverte a été accidentelle
son évolution est le fruit des forts
collectifs plusieurs dizaines d'années
de recherche miniaturisation et
optimisation jusqu'à l'avion du
transistor plus compact la science est
avant tout ça du travail de
l'expérimentation je n'ai pas échoué
j'ai simplement trouvé 10000 solutions
qui ne fonctionnent pas disait Thomas
Edison il y a parfois quelques heureux
hasard mais encore faut-il avoir la
capacité de les saisir quand on les voit
pour espérer changer le monde de demain
[Musique]